you ever see a girl who dates a guy then
breaks up with him and then dates the
next guy who's just like her ex i'm
telling you rachel mcadams cannot stay
away from time-traveling spouses it's
just
you gotta watch out for that [ __ ]
about time so about time is a feel-good
romantic comedy about this guy's a
social outcast he's a social leper he
never really stood out in life but bill
nye not the science guy who plays his
father in the movie comes to him and
he's like okay the males in our family
have the ability to travel through time
what does he want he doesn't want money
he doesn't want riches he doesn't want
glory he doesn't want fame he just wants
a girlfriend which i understand you
don't want to create a crazy paradox and
have that whole biff situation from back
to the future too i get it in any case
he finds rachel mcadams and now we have
a movie that is proof positive that i've
become a really sappy dude because i
really enjoyed this movie seriously
first of all the main character this
dude was really good funny enough he's
portrayed as a socially awkward guy but
when he really gets to talking he is
charming but what can we expect he's
british seriously if blockbuster wasn't
going out of business they would have a
new category titled romantic comedies
with charmingly befuddled male leads
that we can relate to and empathize with
that will then be shrunk down to the
category british i'm not joking about
this yeah hugh grant we remember you but
i really liked this guy and i liked his
relationship with rachel mcadams they
weren't that shitty couple that you see
who either fights all the time or they
don't fight enough and they're all just
sappy sappy they're that couple you
don't mind hanging out with because they
don't drown you in their bizarre
sappiness there what's the word a human
and i like their dialogue they're back
and forth you almost feel like some of
it was ad-lib maybe it was in any case
it came out great and the funny thing is
the trailer pitches it like the entire
movie is based around him trying to get
a date with rachel mcadams but no he
gets a date with rachel mcadams and
after that it's them and they're live
together a life i enjoyed watching
because it also touched on the fact that
you can't change this over here without
changing this over here it reminded me
of imagine butterfly effect meets a nice
feel-good british romantic comedy and
upon watching their life together you
have that forrest gump kind of feeling
where you're like okay it's showing
their life not like you have a focus
point like oh the point of this movie is
for him to save his grandson or anything
like that you're enjoying the movie as
it's going and you realize the movie is
made for us the audience which any movie
is but i'm saying the main point of the
movie is to show us because we've all
thought to ourselves oh if i had a time
machine i'd go back and change this or
i'd alter that this movie's like no
don't do that enjoy life as it is you
don't need time travel i don't know the
deuce name but you know the guy who
played the dick and pirates of the
caribbean dead man's chest and at
world's end he makes every scene he's in
like when he's talking you're like you
are all that matters in this movie at
this moment his lines are so good
they're so good my brain was like i'm
sorry jeremy you don't remember his
lines now that you walked out of the
movie because they are too cool for you
and i concede to that fact he's just
such a bitter artistic dick he's like
billy walsh from entourage but british
point is about time was a fun feel-good
romantic comedy it had time travel
elements and i really like time travel i
like how i portrayed time travel i like
the actors in this movie i liked the
lesson this movie gave us all to live on
fact is women are going to drag their
dudes to this movie and dudes don't have
to hate the fact that they did my
blu-ray collection has grown in 2013
because i would buy about time on
blu-ray funny thing is he's a lawyer in
this movie so he's a time traveling
lawyer that sounds like a really bad
sequel to devil's advocate you feel like
bad things are going to come of the
world now no he's a nice guy and we all
love him alright so if you had time
travel what would you do with that
whatever you do comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you